With more than 170 million Skype users worldwide,...
...Microsoft is betting its newest acquisition will help expand its mobile presence...
...and appeal to corporate users of video and voice communications.
Microsoft CEO Steve Ballmer says it's the biggest deal yet in the company's 36 - year history.
This is a big day for Skype and this is a big day for Microsoft.
We're adding a new division and a new promise to our customers,...
...the promise of universal next generation communications.
But at 8.5 billion dollars, analysts say it's a hefty price tag...
...for a popular but money - losing Internet phone and video conferencing service.
PC Magazine Executive Editor Dan Costa believes Microsoft had to move quickly...
...after reports that Skype was also entertaining offers from Google and Facebook.